this is the world famous Rockefeller
Center founded of course by Theodore
Rockefeller this is a skating rink
and I think the Rangers practice there
sometimes
and it's that's Tina Fey
that's Tina Fey from Saturday Night Live
hello hello hi oh I'm I'm sorry
I thought you were okay
she looked like she looked a lot like
Tina Fey
hello hello I thought that was Santa Fe
was it so
are you serious
he was here when when I was talking to
the fake Tina Fey come on and I was just
you've jacked it did this to her I can't
believe Conan's gonna have Tracy on as a
guest again considering what happened
last time you seemed like you have a
nice chemistry I am a stabbing robot I
will stab you all right no okay all
right all right that's great Tracy we'll
take a break we'll be right back
[Music]
Conan Tracy's really excited to be back
on your show
I Don't Know Jack he's kind of a Loose
Cannon and I like to surround myself
with people that don't try to stab me
well Tracy's feeling a lot better now
he's under a doctor's care yeah that's
what they said about Hasselhoff then he
tried to make out with me during a
commercial break Conan
this is important to me so we can either
do this the easy way or the hard way
what's the hard way you do a live
Christmas Eve special from Kabul every
year until the war on terror is won
tell Tracy I'll see him tonight
you Black Irish bastard back at you man
no ah no
[Music]
all right
hey Liz what's up
oh hi Conan how are you good
you still going out with that guy from
the pager store
oh Dennis
yeah
you still um
how's your wife
let's not do this Elizabeth
vocal warm-ups I'll tell him you came by
okay
[Music]
oh he licked all of those
[Music]
here it is
tonight from his numerous hit movies
including president homeboy and hunk and
Grandma be tripping or you may know him
from his last appearance on this show
when he tried to stab me in the face
okay gotta go excuse me Tracy
[Music]
Tracy Jordan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know you really went above and
beyond for that guy today I just hope we
get away with it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is going on a little long
no don't don't do that hands on pants on
sit in the chair buddies in the chair
sit down Sit oh don't sit down
[Music]
okay
good to have you here that was great and
you're
and he's asleep
which uh is okay because at least he
didn't murder me
and uh Tracy Jordan everybody that was
it did good too crazy
ah
well I got started in the NBC page
program and before you know it I'm
making hit movies with my good friend
and roommate Zach Brath
what who told you that well yes I do
know how to clog but I don't think
anybody wants to see me do that
you do really
okay
you're a weird guy Kenneth see you
tomorrow Mr O'Brien
[Music]
Jenna you've been friends with lemon for
a long time she and I had an argument
yesterday really did this scream in your
face did you pin her up against the wall
were your shirts wet with rain I mean
obviously we've had disagreements before
but this
feels different after tonight I feel
like lemon and I could go our separate
ways and never see each other again is
that crazy not really you know Liz she
can hold a grudge she did want me to
cancel Top Chef because calicchio's
lunch Place changed the topics on her
favorite salad and with people forget
about it she's never stayed friends with
an ex when Conan dumped her she dropped
him forever
hey Liz
come on you can't pretend I don't exist
we dated for a year
we were going to lose our virginity to
each other
now I'll never lose it